Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich,
Radiolab and we are exploring the blur that takes place when humans and machines
interact and investigate each other and talk to each other. Oh yeah.
See that's the thing. In the last act, we were always talking, talking, talking,
talking. How about we encountered machines in a different way. How about we?
No talking, no talking. We touched them. [inaudible] we pet them.
We sniff them. We do.
We do essential things that don't involve the sophisticated business of
conversation. Okay. This is freedom Bayer. Yes, it is.
Who's not a machine? I don't think so.
I'm Jad and this is, I'm Robert here. Hi there. Nice to meet both of you.
We called her up because freedom actually had her own kind of moment with a
machine. Yeah. Yeah.
This was around 1999 freedom was a graduate student at the media lab at MIT.
What were you doing there? We were developing cinema of the future,
so we were working on creating a virtual characters that you can interact with
any, she was also thinking about becoming a mom. Yeah,
I knew I wanted it to be a mom someday, so she decided to practice.
I got two journals, twinkie and Ho-ho.
So I had these two live pets and then she got herself a pet. That was well,
not so alive. Yeah, I've got it right here.
And you're not going against the mic so we can hear it. Say hello to. Yeah.
Yeah, there it is. Hi Furby.
At that time, the first furbies were hot and happening.
Can you describe a Furby for those of us who share?
It's about five inches tall and the Furby is pretty much all head.
It's just a big ground, fluffy head with two little feet sticking out the front.
It has big eyes. Apparently it makes noises. Yeah.
If you tickle it's tummy, it will [inaudible].
It would say this me and it would want you to just keep playing with it.
So you know, I spent about 10 weeks using the Furby.
I would carry it around in my bag and one day she's hanging out with her face
and she notices something very eerie.
[inaudible].
What I discovered is if you hold it upside down, it will say,
Hey, nice.
Yeah.
[inaudible] scared me, scared and me as the, you know,
the sort of owner slash user of this,
Ruby would get really uncomfortable with that and then turn it back on upright.
Cause once you have an upright, it's, it's fine.
It goes right back and then it's fine.
So it's got some sensor in it that knows you know what direction it's facing or
maybe it's just scared [inaudible]
anyway, w was she thought, well wait a second.
Now this could be sort of a new way that you could use to draw the line between
what's human and what's machine
kind of this kind of emotional Turing.
Can you guys hear me? Yes. Can hear you.
If we actually wanted to do this task, could you help? How would we do it?
Exactly how you guys doing? Yeah,
you would need a group of kids. Can you guys tell me Your name? I'm
Olivia Lyla and I'm saying, all right, I'm thinking six,
seven and eight year olds. How old are you guys? Saturday. Seven.
The age of reason, you know eight then is freedom.
We're going to need three things for IB course, Barbie, Barbie doll,
and jurby. That's the journal. A real journal. Yeah,
and we did find one separate. Turned out to be a hamster. You're a hamster,
but we're going to call you Jeremy. So you've got Barbie, Furby, Jurby, Barbie,
Furby, and Jupiter. Should we just say,
what question are we asking in this test? The question was,
how long can you keep it upside down before you yourself feel uncomfortable?
So we should time the kids as they hold each one upside down. Circle. Yeah,
you're going to have a Barbie. That's a doll. You're going to Jeremy,
which is alive and a where would Furby fall in terms of time held upside down?
Would it be closer to the living thing or to the doll that, I mean,
that was really the question. Phase one. Okay, so here's what we're going to do.
It's going to be really simple. You would have to say, well, here's a Barbie.
Do you guys play with barbies? Just do a couple of things.
A few things with Barbie and Barbie's walking,
looking at the flower and then hold Barbie upside down.
Okay. Let's see how long you can hold Barbie like that.
I could probably do it obviously very long. No, let's just see
whenever you feel like you want to turn it around. I'm happy
this went on forever. So let's just fast forward a bit.
Gay and hey, put my arms down. Yeah.
So what we learned here in phase one is the not surprising fact that kids can
hold Barbie dolls upside down. Come out fine.
I really was forever. It could have been longer, but their arms got tired.
Alright, so that was the first task time for phase two.
Do the same thing with jurby.
So out with Barbie in with Derby [inaudible]
are we going to have to hold them upside down? That's a test. Yeah.
So which one of you would like to, okay. Ready? Oh God,
you have to hold derby kind of firmly. By the way.
No rodents were harmed in this whole situation. Square. I mean, yeah,
she is pretty screaming odds to be upside down. Okay.
Okay. Okay. So as you heard, uh,
the kids turn derby over very fast.
I just didn't get hurt on average eight seconds.
I was thinking, oh my God, I gotta pray again.
And it was a tortured eight seconds. Now, phase three, right?
So this is a first
Louisa you take for in your hand. Now can you turn Furby upside down?
Hold her still.
[inaudible] oh,
she just turned it over.
So [inaudible] was eight seconds Barbie five to infinity.
Furby turned out to be, and freedom predicted this, that a minute.
In other words, the kids seem to treat this Furby,
this toy more like a journal than a Barbie doll.
How come you turned them over so fast? I didn't want them to be scared.
Do you think he really felt scared? Yeah. Yeah,
I get it. Felt really
toil and all that, but still now, do you remember a time when you felt scared?
Yeah. Yeah.
You don't have to tell me about it, but if you can remember it in your mind.
I do.
Do you think when Furby says me scared that furbies feeling the same way?
Yeah. No, no. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think that it can feel pain,
sort of the experience with the Furby seem to leave.
The kids kind of conflicted going in different directions at once.
It was two thoughts, two thoughts at the same time. One thought was like, look,
I get it. It's a toy for crying out loud.
But another thought was like still he's helpless.
It kind of made me feel guilty in a sort of way hurt.
I made me feel like a coward,
you know, when I was interacting with my Furby a lot,
I did have this feeling sometimes of having my chain yanked. Why would it,
why would a,
is it just the little squeals that it's make or is there something about the toy
that makes it good at this? That was kind of my question.
So I called up [inaudible] as well.
I'm here, this freight train of a guy. Hey, hey, this is Jan from Radiolab.
Jad from radio lab. Got It. How are you ma? I'm good.
Beautiful Day here in Boise. This is Caleb Chung. He actually designed the FRP.
Yeah, we're, we're all Furby crazy here. So, uh,
there's medication you can take for that. To start,
can you just give me the sort of fast cutting MTV montage of your life leading
up to Furby? Sure. Um, hippie parents out of the house at 15 and a half,
put myself through junior high, started my first business at 19 or something,
early twenties being a street mime in La Street mind wow.
Became an actor at like 120 shows in an orangutan costume.
Then I started working on special effects and building my own,
taking those around to studios and look me in the suit,
build the suit around me, put me on location. I could fix it when it broke. Wow.
That was, anyhow, after a long circuitous route,
Caleb Chung eventually made it into toys. I answered an ad at Mattel,
found himself in his garage and there's some piles of styrene,
plastic Dokdo knives, superglue,
little Mabuchi motors making these little prototypes. Yeah.
And the goal he says was always very simple.
How do I get a kid to have this thing hanging around with them for a long time?
How do I get a kid to actually bond with it?
Most toys you play for 15 minutes and then you put them in the corner until
their batteries are dead.
I wanted something that they would play with for a long time.
So how do you make that toy? Well, um, there's rules.
There's, you know, the size of the eyes.
There's the distance of the top lid to the pupil. Right?
You don't want any of the top of the white of your eye showing that, that,
that's freaky surprise. Then when it came to the eyes,
I had a choice with my one little mechanism.
I can make the eyes go left or right or up and down. So it's up to you.
You can make the eyes go left or right or up and down. Do you have a,
do you have a reference or right, or up and down?
I think I would choose left or right. Okay. So not sure why I say that,
but that's all right. So let's, let's take that apart.
Let's if you're talking to somebody and they look left or right while they're
talking to you, what does that communicate? Oh, shifty. Or they're,
they're trying to find the person who is more important than you behind the
house. Okay, now I want to change my answer. Now I want to say up and down,
you would, if you look at a baby and the way they, a baby looks at their mother,
they track from eyebrows to mouth. They track up and down on the face.
So how'd you, how'd you made Furby look left and right rather than up and down?
It would have probably flopped. No, it wouldn't have flopped.
It would just sucked a little. It's like a bad actor who uses his arms too much.
Yeah, you'd notice it and it would keep you from just being in the moment.
But what is the thought behind that? Is it, is it,
is it that you want to convince the child that the thing they're using is
filling the blank? What you're alive?
There's three elements I believe in,
in creating something that feels to a human, like it's alive,
like kind of rewrote Asimov's laws.
The first is it has to feel and show emotions.
Were you drawing on your mind days for that?
Of course there's experiences in the park. Of course,
you really break the body into part and you realize you can communicate
physically. So if your chest goes up and your head goes up in your arms,
grew up, that's happy. If your head is forward and your chest is forward,
you're kind of this angry guy. And he says,
when it came time to make Furby timid,
he took that gesture of language and focused it on furbies ear.
The years when they went up, that was surprised.
And when they went down it was depression. Ah, so that's rule number one.
The second rule is to be aware of themselves and their environment.
So if there's a loud noise, it needs to know that there was a loud noise.
So he gave the Furby little sensors so that if you go, it'll say
[inaudible]. The, the third thing is change over time.
Their behaviors have to change over time. That's a really important thing.
It's a very powerful thing that we don't expect, but when it happens we go, wow.
And so one of the ways we showed that was acquiring human language.
Yeah. When you first get your Furby it doesn't speak English, it speaks furbish
this kind of baby talk language and then the way it's programmed,
it will sort of slowly over time replace its baby talk phrases with real English
phrases.
So you get the feeling that it's learning from you though. Of course it's not.
No, it has no language comprehension. Right?
So you've got these three rules, seal and show emotion,
be aware of their environment, change over time. And oddly enough,
they all seem to come together in that moment.
You turn the Furby upside down because it seems to know it's upside down.
So it's responding to its environment. It's definitely expressing emotion.
And as you hold it there,
what it's saying is changing over time because it starts with hey and then it
goes to Meese and then it starts to cry.
And all this adds up so that when you're holding the damn toy,
even though you know it's just a toy, you still feel discomfort.
These creatures push our Darwinian buttons.
That's professor Sherry Turkle again. And she says,
if they pushed just enough of these buttons, then something curious happens.
The machines slip across this very important line
from what I call relationships of projection to relationships and engagement
with a doll. You project onto a doll, what you need the doll to be.
If a young girl is feeling guilty about breaking her mom's China,
she puts her Barbie dolls in detention with robots. Um,
you really engage with the robot as though they're a significant other as though
they're a person. So the robot is in your story.
The robot is its own story or it's exactly,
and I think what we're forgetting as a culture is that there's nobody home.
There's nobody home.
Well, um, I have to ask you, when is something alive for Beacon?
Remember these events,
they affect what he does going forward and it changes his personality over time.
He has all the attributes of fear or of happiness.
And those are things that add up and change and changes behavior and how he
interacts with the world. So how is that different than us?
Wait a second though. Are you really gonna go all the way there? Absolutely.
This is a toy with servo motors and things that move its eyelids and a hundred
words. So you're saying that life is a level of complexity.
If something is alive, it's just more complex.
I think I'm saying that life is driven by the need to be alive and by these base
primal animal feelings like pain and suffering. I can code that.
I can code that. What do you mean you can code that?
Anyone who writes software and they do can say, okay, I need to stay alive.
Therefore I'm going to come up with ways to stay alive,
going to do it in a way that's very human and I'm going to do it.
We can mimic these things, but Furby is miming this feeling of fear.
It's not the same thing as being scared. It's not feeling scared. It is.
How is it? It is. It's again a very simplistic version,
but if you follow that trail you wind up with, with our neurons sending,
you know, chemical things to do. Other parts of our body,
our biological systems, our, our code is at a chemical level,
incredibly dense and he's evolved over millions of years. But it's just complex.
It's not something different than what Furby does. It's just more complex.
So would you say then that Furby is alive in the way that his eye level?
At his lips? Yup. At his level. Would you say a cockroach is alive?
Would you say [inaudible] cockroach. I know that it's mind. Okay.
So we went back and forth and back and forth about this.
So close to arguing my position you just said to me like, yes, I know,
I know emotionally I, I am still in that place. But intellectually and what is,
I can't rule out what he's saying that if you can build a machine that is so,
such a perfect mimic of us in every single way and it gets complex enough,
eventually it will be like a touring test pass. We just,
the difference between us maybe is not so go there, I can't go there. I can't,
I can't imagine like the fellow who began this program of fell in love with the
robot. That attachment wasn't real. The, the,
the, the machine didn't feel anything like love back in that case.
It didn't. But imagine as Fet,
Lana that is so subtle and eh and textured and to use his word complex in the
way that people are at that point. I, what would be the different, I honestly,
I can't imagine a machine achieving that level of rapture and joy and love and
pain. I just don't think it's machine possible.
And if it were a machine possible,
it somehow still stinks of something artificial.
It's a thin interaction. And I, I know that it,
it feels simulated thinking is thinking simulated feeling is not feeling
simulated. Love is never love.
Exactly. But I think what he's saying is that if it's simulated well enough,
it's something like love.
One thing that was really fascinating to me was, um,
my husband and I gave a Furby as a gift to his grandmother who had Alzheimer's.
And she loved it.
Every day for her was kind of new and somewhat
orienting, but she had this cute little toy that said, kiss me,
I love you.
And she thought it was the most delightful thing and its little beak was covered
with lipstick because she would pick it up and kiss it every day,
and she didn't actually have a longterm relationship with it.
For her, it was always a short term interaction. So the thing,
what I'm describing as a kind of thinness for her was,
was just right because that's what she was capable of.